au début de la quarantaine Adam Smith
est à Toulouse vous le savez peut-être
cette ville est aujourd'hui un des
centres de l'enseignement de l'économie
en Europe notamment grâce à la Toulouse
School of Economics TSE mais au 18e
siècle Adam Smith se fait chier à
Toulouse non seulement il ne trouve pas
la ville intéressante mais en plus il ne
reçoit pas les lettres de recommandation
qu'on lui a promise ce qui fait que sa
vie sociale est limitée il se sent seul
et il s'ennuie il rêve d'une excursion à
Bordeaux et il cherche une occupation
pour tromper l'ennui alors pour tuer le
temps il comm commence à écrire un livre
ce livre c'est la richesse des nations
la première pierre de l'économie
[Musique]
moderne l'écossais du 18e siècle Adam
Smith est souvent considéré comme le
père de l'économie moderne et son
chef-dœuvre la richesse des nations
serait la bible du libéralisme parce
qu'il ériigge la liberté économique la
concurrence et le marché en concept
fondateur du capitalisme mais il y a pas
mal de choses qu'on ne vous a pas dites
sur Adam Smith par exemple il n'est pas
économiste il n'a aucune expérience du
commerce et ses grandes idées viennent
de France il y a un grand écart entre ce
que l'on pense savoir de Smith et la
réalité dans cette vidéo je vais vous
dévoiler 10 anecdotes surprenantes sur
sa vie et sa pensée des révélations que
vous ne trouverez pas dans un cours ou
dans un livre d'économie restez bien
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo parce que
j'ai percé le mystère de la célébrité du
père de l'économie et je vous l'explique
dans les dernières
anecdotes à l'âge de 4 ans Adam Smith se
rend chez son grand-père et disparaît en
chemin il reste introuvable un certain
temps un homme rencontre une femme
gitane dans les environs elle porte un
enfant qui n'arrête pas de pleurer
l'homme trouve qu'il y a quelque chose
de bizarre donc il envoie les
patrouilleurs quand il tombe sur la
femme gitane elle jette le petit enfant
à terre comme un paquet pour s'enfuir
les patrouilleurs identifient Adam Smith
et le ramènent chez lui cette anecdote
est un peu mystérieuse parce que le
motif de l'enlèvement n'a rien d'évident
la famille d'Adam Smith est modeste donc
ça n'a aucun sens de demander une rançon
et le biographe ne nous nous dit rien de
plus il n'est pas impossible que
l'histoire soit en partie inventée et
qu'elle exprime simplement les préjugés
de l'époque contre les gitans mais si je
vous raconte cette anecdote c'est parce
qu'elle illustre l'enfance plutôt
malchanceuse d'Adam Smith son père un
avocat qui s'appelle aussi Adam Smith
meurt quelques mois avant sa naissance
donc la mère d'Adam Smith va l'élever
seule c'est déjà pas facile à notre
époque mais çaelle était encore plus au
18e siècle Adam Smith va donc grandir
dans des conditions modeste je le
signale parce que beaucoup de penseurs
sont issus de milieu privilégiés mais sa
mère va veiller à son éducation et lui
donner beaucoup
d'amour Adam Smith disait souvent je ne
suis beau que dans mes livres au moins
il ne se menent pas à lui-même c'est
vrai qu'il est estit les gens qui le
connaissent disent qu'il a un physique
étrange un grand nez des yeux exorbités
une lèvre inférieure saillante et pour
ne rien arranger il a un tic nerveux un
défaut d'élocution et même un
tremblement de tête qui serait né lors
d'un burnout de lecture bref Adam Smith
est loin d'être un beau gosse
charismatique est-ce que ça explique
quelque chose moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est parce qu'il il avait un physique
et plus globalement une présence
repoussante qu'Adam Smith a développé ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque le goût de
l'étude c'est-à-dire une capacité
supérieur de travail intellectuel en
particulier de concentration pour la
lecture et l'écriture et une certaine
puissance intellectuelle comme
l'extérieur et décevant il a une riche
vie intérieure et puis ça l'attache
encore plus à sa mère il est fou d'elle
il est toujours resté très proche d'elle
et il a même vécu avec elle jusqu'à ce
qu'elle meurt 6 ans avant lui et du coup
comme le souligné avec le sourire
Jean-Marc Daniel dans ses cours
d'économie à l'ESCP Adam Smith n'a connu
aucune femme dit plus directement il est
resté puceau il n'aimait que sa
mère un matin Adam Smith se retrouve à
25 km de chez lui les cloches de
l'église le ramènent à la réalité en
sonnant à 6h Adam Smith se rend compte
qu'il est en chemise de nuit qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il a été enlevé par des
extraterrestres non c'est simplement un
des traits de la personnalité d'Adam
Smith il se perd très facilement dans
ses pensées on pourrait penser qu'il
fait simplement du somnambulisme mais il
peut pe se perdre dans ses pensées dans
n'importe quelle circonstance ça lui
arrive très souvent par exemple il
participe à une conversation animée lors
d'un dîner et d'un coup vous le perdez
il est dans un rêve éveillé un ami
raconte qu'il l'a vu préparer du thé
avec un regard bizarre et qu'il a mis du
pain et du beurre dans la tayère autre
exemple il visite une usine de tanage et
il tombe dans une immense fosse de
tanage heureusement qu'il y avait du
monde pour l'aider à en sortir bref Adam
Smith perd souvent le contact avec la
réalité ça fait de lui un personnage
excentrique les gens qui le connaissent
ont plein d'anecdotes à raconter sur lui
et il semble qu'il a été comme ça dès
l'enfance il se parlait à lui-même et il
avait parfois des conversations avec des
amis imaginaire cette anecdote montre
que si Adam Smith est lait et maladroit
il marque tout de même ses contemporains
par son
originalité nous sommes au début des
années 1740 c'est la fin de
l'adolescence pour Adam Smith il étudie
à la prestigieuse université d'Oxford
grâce à une bourse il l'a obtenu parce
qu'il était un excellent élève un jour
un surveillant le sur surprend en train
de lire le Traité de la nature humaine
de David hum Adam Smith se fait non
seulement confisquer le livre mais en
plus le surveillant le signale aux
autorités qui punissent sévèrement
l'étudiant pour avoir consulté ce livre
c'est quoi le problème avec le Traité de
la nature humaine de David humum et bien
humum qui était un penseur des lumières
écossaises était un auteur subversif
pour les autorités religieuses elle ne
se donnait pas le mal d'aller dans le
détail de sa pensée elle le stigmatise
simplement comme un dangereux athé donc
comme Oxford était une université liée
aux autorités relig use il ne fallait
pas lire yum dans son enceinte cette
anecdote montre qu'Adam Smith est attiré
par les idées et par l'attitude
intellectuelle des lumières il deviendra
d'ailleurs une des figures les plus
importantes des lumières écossaises il
est particulièrement rétiscent à l'égard
des questions et des obligations
religieuse il refuse de faire un cours
pour défendre la doctrine chrétienne il
fait scandale en souriant ostensiblement
pendant la messe ou encore il demande le
droit de ne pas commencer ses cours par
une prière bien sûr cette attitude ne
tombe pas du ciel l'homme est toujours
le produit de son milieu et Adam Smith
gravite dans le milieu des lumières il
est profondément influencé par Francis
Hutcheson son professeur de philosophie
morale à l'Université de Glasgow or ce
prof fait de la philosophie avec une
grande liberté de penser pour l'époque
ce qui lui vaut d'ailleurs des ennuis
Smith est également très proche de David
humum qui a une dizaine d'années de plus
que lui enfin Smith est fan de Voltaire
Rousseau et de kessne un des économistes
les plus influents des Lumières
françaises au milieu des années 1760 des
bustes d'Adam Smith à appisse dans les
vitrines des librairies de Glasgow où il
est prof à l'Université il a 37 ans et
on vend déjà des bustes à son effigie
mais attendez son che d'œuvre la
richesse des nations il ne l'écrit
qu'une dizaine d'années plus tard je me
serais pas trompé dans les dates et bien
non je ne me suis pas trompé parce
qu'Adam Smith est d'abord une star de la
philo avant d'être une star de
l'économie il est prof de philosophie
morale à l'Université de Glasgow ses
cours sont parmi ceux que les élèves
préfèrent parce que Smith dit des choses
intéressantes pour capter leur attention
parce qu'il s'écarte du programme
classique et qu'il évoque des idées
nouvelles mais sa notoriété explose en
1759 avec la publication de sa théorie
des sentiments moraux il devient
immédiatement un des plus grands
écrivains contemporains des auteurs
célèbres font des critiques élogieuses
du livre ils reconnaissent que ces idées
sont à la fois nouvelles et profondes
j'ai résumé les idées essentiel du livre
sur le site 1 idé de culture générale
dès lors la popularité d'Adam Smith ne
cesse de grandir ça devient la mode
d'assister à ces cours même les jeunes
hommes de l'élite locale qui n'en ont
rien à faire de l'université viennent
écouter Adam Smith des étudiants
viennent de l'étranger pour suivre ses
cours il arrive alors à Adam Smith ce
qu'il arrive aux gens célèbres on se met
à limiter à caricaturer sa voix et sa
prononciation mais surtout son influence
intellectuelle grandit ses idées et plus
fondamentalement son raisonnement et son
ouverture intellectuelle qui sont
typique d'un penseur des Lumières se
répandent dans la jeunesse privilégiée
de Glasgow je trouve que cette anecdote
est cruciale parce qu'elle révèle
l'origine philosophique de l'économie
l'homme qu'on appelle le père de
l'économie était d'abord un philosophe
des Lumières il n'était pas un
mathématique
ou un physicien mais un écrivain avec
une grande culture littéraire il
s'intéressait aux questions économiques
en même temps qu'il s'intéressait à la
littérature et à l'art pardon pour
l'inruption mais j'ai une question à
vous poser vous croyez vraiment que les
gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose et
oui il y a 24 heur dans une journée et
il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se gardent bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien no ch dans
votre boîte mail après avoir regardé
cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo le 18 octobre 1766 un des deux
élèves dont Adam Smith est le précepteur
est assassiné dans les rues de Paris il
a 19 ans bien sûr Adam Smith et l'autre
élève sont très affectés ils rentrent
immédiatement à Londres c'est la fin de
leur grand tour ce voyage prolongé à
travers l'Europe grâce auxquel les
jeunes hommes de l'élite occidentale
acquéient une expérience pratique et des
compétences sociales qui n'était pas
enseigné dans les salles de classe c'est
cette tradition qui a permis à Adam
Smith de vivre à l'étranger malgré ses
moyens modestes après il n'a pas réussi
à être engagé comme précepteur du
premier coup parce que sa bizarrerie
n'inspirait pas confiance mais au début
de la quarantaine sa célébrité change la
donne il reçoit une offre qu'il ne peut
pas refuser couverture de toutes ses
dépenses de voyage plus le double de son
salaire de prof d'université plus le
même montant comme pension mensuelle à
vie une fois qu'il sera revenu du voyage
c'est une super offre parce qu'à
l'époque en Écosse les profs
d'université n'ont souvent aucun revenu
garanti ils ont parfois du mal à joindre
les debouts il donnent beaucoup de cours
particuliers certains jusqu'à la fin de
leur carrière donc Adam Smith accepte
l'offre avec ses élèves ils se rendent
notamment à Toulouse à Bordeaux qu'Adam
Smith préfère largement à Toulouse à
Genève et surtout à Paris ils y
séjournent pendant un peu moins d'un an
cette anecdote révèle l'influence des
Lumières françaises sur la pensée d'Adam
Smith et donc sur la fondation de
l'économie comme discipline
intellectuelle moderne en effet à Paris
Smith rencontre contre certains des
intellectuels et des économistes les
plus importants de l'époque même s'il
parle en français pas terrible non
seulement il a des lettres de
recommandation mais en plus la
traduction de sa théorie des sentiments
moraux lui donne un certain crédit il se
rend régulièrement dans les salons
littéraires les plus réputés et
participe au mondanité comme jamais dans
sa vie il va souvent au théâtre en
particulier il fréquente beaucoup les
physiocrthes le fondateur de cette école
économique le médecin kessnet insiste
sur l'importance de la circulation des
richesses qu'il compare à la circulation
du sang dans le corps c'est ce qui
inspirera à Adam Smith sa défense du
libre
échange comme je vous l'ai dit Adam
Smith est fan de Voltaire mais ça ne
l'empêche pas d'aimer aussi l'ennemi de
Voltaire l'autre pôle idéologique des
Lumières françaises Jean-Jacques
Rousseau Adam Smith a même de l'empathie
pour Rousseau il regrette ses problèmes
ses déménagements répétés et son
anonymat forcé en 1782 Adam Smith dit à
un ami français un jour le contrat
social vengera Rousseau de toutes les
persécutions qu'il a subi de la la part
du pouvoir le père de l'économie prédit
la Révolution française au début de la
décennie qui va changer l'histoire de
l'Hexagone il sent qu'un soulèvement se
prépare et il sent que le soulèvement
accouchera d'une nouvelle distribution
des forces politiques inspirées par la
pensée de Rousseau Adam Smith se rend
bien compte de l'oppression et de la
détresse de la population lors de son
séjour en France il comprend que le
pouvoir empêche les initiatives de
réforme ce qui rend la situation
explosive à ses yeux si les Français
sont plus pauvres que les Anglais c'est
à cause de la fisc ité il estime que la
fiscalité française relève de
l'oppression non seulement les impôts
sont trop élevés mais ils sont injustes
et mal prélevés après la Révolution
française l'idéologie révolutionnaire
sera en effet associée à la pensée de
Rousseau mais aussi à celle d'Adam Smith
en particulier à sa doctrine du libre
échange voici ce qu'il s'est passé lors
du dernier cours d'Adam Smith avant
qu'il ne quitte Glasgow pour sa mission
de précepteur à la fin du cours il tire
des enveloppes de ses poches et dans ses
enveloppes il a mis les sommes corres
espondant au frais de scolarité de ses
étudiants en tout cas au moins ce qui
lui ont payé en trop par rapport au
cours auquel ils ont déjà assisté il est
réglo c'est la morale commerciale de
base il appelle le premier élève pour
lui donner son enveloppe mais là le
jeune homme refuse fermement il dit que
l'instruction et le plaisir qu'il a reçu
d'Adam Smith sont bien supérieurs à ceux
qu'il a payé et que c'est lui en réalité
qui a une dette envers le professeur et
là tous les autres élèves se mettent à
crier pour dire la même chose Adam Smith
est très apprécié par ses étudiants non
seulement il est un prof intéressant
mais il a des qualités humaines qui le
rendent très attachants beaucoup de ses
étudiants gardent un très bon souvenir
de lui et le recommandent même à
d'autres familles certains restent en
contact avec lui en lui manifestant un
respect affectueux jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie le jeune homme dont il a été le
précepteur celui qui n'est pas mort ce
jeune homme le considérera toute sa vie
comme son mentor et c'est pareil avec
ses amis et plus généralement avec ses
connaissances Adam Smith est un homme
agréable facile à vivre et qui suscite
spontanément la sympathie pour la petite
histoire il réussit quand même à
remettre les enveloppe à ses élèves il
les remercie puis il leur explique qu'il
se sentira mal s'il ne les rembourse pas
et alors il saisit l'élève le plus
proche de lui et par le manteau il lui
bourre l'enveloppe dans la poche et il
le repousse tout le monde dans la classe
comprend qu'il faut prendre
l'enveloppe si les étudiants aiment
beaucoup Adam Smith il y a quand même
des frictions notamment à propos de la
prise de note lorsqu'Adam Smith remarque
qu'un élève prend beaucoup de notes il
l'arrête immédiatement et il lui dit je
déteste l'ISCR Bouillard c'est bizarre
ça je ne sais pas vous mais moi c'était
l'inverse les profs nous poussaient à
prendre le plus de notes possible et au
contraire il s'énervaiit si on ne notait
rien alors c'est quoi le problème avec
Adam Smith et bien il a peur qu'on lui
vole ses idées en effet la particularité
de son cours c'est qu'il repose sur des
idées originales qui ne sont pas dans
les manuels et à l'époque il y a des
abus certains étudiants revendent leur
notes de cours à des éditeurs et alors
les idées original du prof se retrouve
diffusé dans le grand public sans qu'il
en soit reconnu comme l'auteur ni bien
sûr qu'il soit rémunéré pour son travail
certains libraires vendent même
directement les notes des étudiants dans
leur boutiqu c'est pour ça qu'Adam Smith
est comme la plupart des penseurs des
Lumières un fervant partisan de la
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle après d'après certains
biographes il n'empêche pas non plus ses
étudiants de prendre des notes il
surveille simplement les
abus vous connaissez margarte toucher
elle a été à la tête du Royaume-Uni en
tant que première ministre de 1979 à
1990 elle incarne le retour du
capitalisme libéral après les décennies
de kenésianisme et la légende raconte
qu'elle avait toujours un exemplaire de
la richesse des nations dans son sac à
main le chef-dœuvre d'Adam Smith est
donc un symbole du capitalisme libéral
mais Margaret toucher a-t-elle lu ce
livre très probablement pas en fait les
gens ne lisent pas la richesse des
nations il y a même une blague
d'économiste qui dit que l'économiste
qui a lu la richesse des nations n'est
pas encore né pourquoi les gens ne
lisent-ils pas la richesse des nations
et comment se fait-il que les idées de
ce livre soient pourtant si influentes
réponse à la première question la raison
principale pour laquelle ce livre livre
est pe lu c'est qu'il fait 1000 pages et
qu'il n'est vraiment pas agréable à lire
l'expression est lourde même parfois
maladroite mal structuré sans méthode
personnellement je me suis arrêté au
bout de 300 pages d'après les propres
amis d'Adam Smith c'est mal écrit alors
que le style de la théorie des
sentiments moraux est bien meilleure la
richesse des nations est mal écrit parce
qu'Adam Smith a dicté tandis qu'il a
écrit lui-même la théorie des sentiments
moraux maintenant réponse à la seconde
question en fait les idées fondatrices
du capitalisme libéral qui sont dans la
richesse des nations était déjà dans
l'air à l'époque et ce livre est bien
davantage le symbole de ces idées que
leur véritable source au début dans
l'Angleterre d'Adam Smith le livre sert
de caution intellectuelle aux hommes
politiques qui veulent libéraliser
l'économie et il y aura même un décalage
important entre le contenu réel de la
richesse des nations et l'idée que s'en
fera l'opinion publique occidentale je
vous donne deux exemples la fameuse
métaphore de la main invisible
n'apparaît qu'une seule fois dans le
livre dans un sens peu clair alors que
la postérité en fera le le concept
majeur d'Adam Smith second exemple Smith
dit très clairement que la division du
travail abrutit les hommes et donc il
nous prévient que la croissance
économique se fera au détriment du
bonheur du peuple qu'elle sacrifiera
l'épanouissement individuel des ouvriers
ça c'est une limite importante que les
profs d'économie oublient de mentionner
probablement parce qu'ils n'ont pas lu
la richesse des nations Adam Smith avait
peur que ses élèves lui volent ses idées
en fait il aurait dû craindre que la
postérité ne les
déforme si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture expresse c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en science en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
cours de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toutes circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable est
passionnant Maxens m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitre est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommander votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ces discussion les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture général si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore tapeer
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée